on Sunday night moonlight shocked
America by defeating heavily favored
Best Picture competitor lala Lin and one
for one simple reason those in Hollywood
decided that intersectionality should
defeat Hollywood self-aggrandizement
this year here's the thing about
moonlight it's not a very good movie
it's interesting in the way that all
character studies are kind of
interesting it's a look at a place and
at a time and at a person but it doesn't
truly uplift or sore or actually do much
of anything it won because the Academy
voters preferred not to hear another
year of griping about hashtag
oscarssowhite and because those same
voters could feel good about supposedly
slapping Donald Trump in the face with
diversity it's no coincidence that an
Oscar ceremony that open with Kimmel
tweeting president a tweaking president
Trump remember last year when it seemed
like the Oscars was racist ended with
the Academy giving the best picture
oscar to Brokeback inner-city Miami this
isn't to say there can't be a great
movie made about a black gay
coming-of-age story there can but this
wasn't it this isn't the first time the
Academy has vowed to political
correctness rather than quality of
course and this year's Oscar battle
featured two battling Hollywood
priorities honoring itself and honoring
the most politically correct picture of
the year in recent years this battle has
become pretty much the entirety of the
best picture race in 2014 Hollywood
rewarded at own importance with Birdman
instead of the far superior whiplash or
American sniper in 2013 Hollywood
rewarded the rather forgettable 12 years
of slave instead of gravity or Dallas
buyers club in 2012 Hollywood gave an
Oscar to Argo yay Hollywood does foreign
policy instead of zero dark thirty or
Lincoln in 2005 Hollywood had his
biggest pc off in a Best Picture fight
between Brokeback Mountain crash and
Munich Capote was actually a better
picture than all of those three one of
the reasons Hollywood no longer rakes in
the big bucks other than on tentpole
features is that it sees only the
profound movies as those that Center on
intersectional concerns upholding the
virtue of identity politics or the
importance of art itself rather than
movies to tell people stories that they
want to see lala land is a far better
more watchable movie than moonlight but
there were at least three other movies
that were better than either this year
hell or highwater arrival and hacksaw
ridge and all three were nominated that
doesn't include what I felt was the most
entertaining flick of the year 10
Cloverfield Lane unfortunately for those
pictures they weren't concerned with
black gay children of the wonders of
Hollywood if somebody ever makes a movie
about a half black half Native American
bisexual transgender trying to make his
or her way in Hollywood you can hand
them the Oscar right now and this is how
you know how it was
instead of telling particular stories
with general appeal how it would tell
stories that appeal only to themselves
they reassure themselves with their
importance every single year either by
making movies telling them how important
they are or by making movies trying to
show how important they are by taking on
the issue of the day in after-school
special fashion it doesn't make for good
entertainment which is why TV rat which
actually tells stories rather than
getting up hung up on the self-important
nonsense of the movie industry now
outranks the movie industry in terms of
quality I'm Ben Shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
so we'll talk everything Oscars in just
a minute we will also be talking about
the Democrats cooking a new leader and
what you need to know about Tom Perez
that new leader but first we have to say
thank you to our sponsors over at my
patriots apply so if you're concerned
about the failure of local government to
help you in time of need if you're
concerned about economic downturn if
you're concerned about a natural
disaster you know the levees breaking
like it in Northern California or New
Orleans you're worried about just a
natural disaster of any sort of tornado
and you need to make sure that you are
safe and secure and that you have what
you need for your family you need to
talk to my friends in my patriots apply
they have a four-week emergency food
supply for only 99 bucks which is a
pretty solid price for four weeks of
emergency food supply and something you
buy once and then you never really have
to buy again these things last for 25
years you order now at 888 803 1413 88
88 0 3 14 13 or you can go online to
prepare with Ben com that's breakfast
lunch and dinner for 28 days so in case
the government can't help you or your
local community can't help you you're
prepared and for 99 bucks you never have
to worry about it again it stays fresh
again for 25 years it's only 99 bucks
plus free shipping limit two per caller
because you don't really have to worry
about it beyond that 888 803 1413 now
prepare with been calm again if you're
truly concerned you should be about
making sure your family has enough food
to eat if a crisis hits whether it's an
economic crisis or a natural disaster
you talk to my friends over my patriots
apply living in California this is one
of the companies that we turn to with
regard to to helping out friends and
family when given the fact that the
earthquakes are real possibility out
here and everywhere across the country
there is the possibility of natural
disaster you need to talk to my friends
over at my patriots apply 8888 03 14 13
8888 03 14 13 prepare with been calm is
the place to go online to get your my
patriots apply four weeks supply of
emergency food okay so we can jump right
into the oscar so the big winner at the
Oscars last night was not moonlight the
big winner at the Oscars last night was
Donald Trump that was the big winner at
the Oscars last night because Donald
Trump basically could sit there and
watch hollywood make a mockery of itself
sally kohn one of my favorite people on
the left of MSNBC and CNN pain you
remember her hands up don't shoot sally
kohn tweeted out right before the oscars
that she hoped every single speech was
political
switch I tweeted so do so does have a
Republican in the country we all want
every speech to be political because the
more political these speeches are the
better off Republicans are because
watching all of these all of these sort
of comforted rich limousine liberal
socialists ripping on America is really
something that off puts a lot of voters
and people react to that by voting for
people on the Republican side of the
aisle Hollywood has never driven people
into the arms of the Democrat except
through kind of their subtle cultural
moment but they don't drive people into
the arms of the Democrats by you
shouting about how terrible Republicans
are there something that Hollywood gets
wrong the stuff that Hollywood is good
at creating story creating character
that stuff can help convince people that
Democrats are right but it doesn't
convince people Democrats are right when
Marlon Brando sends up Sheen little
feather at the Oscars in 1973 Native
American spokeswoman to pick up his
award and rant and rave about how
America's mean to the Native Americans
nobody voted Democrat because of that
the nobody voted Democrat in 2003
because Michael Moore got up at the
Oscars and talked about the fictional
president george w bush getting us into
a fictional war Hollywood people think
that we want to hear what they have to
say we don't we want to hear the stories
they have to tell but we don't actually
want to hear the things they have to say
because the things i have to say are
generally stupid they don't know
anything about politics so why in the
world would we listen to them when it
comes to politics but again Hollywood
doesn't know that so instead what
Hollywood does is they think that we're
watching because we want to hear their
opinions on politics so Jimmy Kimmel
just couldn't help himself he opened up
with a bunch of jokes about Trump here
were just a few of them and it was it
was joke after joke about Donald Trump
it has terrible Trump was and look how
wonderful we are we love Meryl Streep
and Meryl Streep's the best because she
made fun of Donald Trump that one time
and some ceremony and yeah we love her
and sure she was in a really crappy
movie Forrest foster Jenkins that nobody
ever saw but it doesn't matter because
Meryl Streep guys Meryl Streep so he
does to all of these jokes in a row
about Donald Trump and we're all
supposed to sit there and be like yeah
this is great yeah the real reaction is
can you guys get over yourselves please
we'll really this is the best that you
can do these are your best jokes about
Donald Trump calling him racist and
calling presumably the people who voted
for him racist as if it's a great way to
a lien 8 an audience it's already not
watching any of your best picture
nominees nothing that was nominated for
best picture this year did well at the
box office I think the only exception of
as far as a movie that did well at the
box office was arrival I'm not aware of
any other movie that was nominated for
best picture this year that's in over
100 million
did a rival end up doing a hundred
million in business if it did it was
real close so it was it was not it was
not you know a blockbuster blow out of
the ballpark it was a good movie i
enjoyed it but all of the movies that
were nominated this year again were seen
by pretty much the people in this
particular room and then it didn't stop
there the self aggrandizement of
hollywood is just unending viola davis
won best supporting actress for her role
in Suicide Squad no no no sorry was no
not for Suicide Squad it was dudes for
her role in what was the name of that
moving fences fences sorry sorry I got
that wrong but Viola Davis who was I
thought she was fantastic in Suicide
Squad that's why i thought that she had
to win so was that guy who likes shot
fired from his fingers never to anyone
Viola Davis she gets up and she gives
this speech we're the only profession
the only one that celebrates what it
means to live a life sounds complaining
before this before the show started
today that I'm kind of tired you know
the reason I'm kind of tired today
because my wife has woken up the last
several mornings at four o'clock in the
morning go into the hospital because she
is a she is a doctor and she's in her
residency which means she's getting up
at four o'clock in the morning to help
people who in some cases are terminally
ill clearly the only profession that
cares about living a life that honors
and celebrates living a life is
Hollywood and it's so just really when
viola davis says stuff like this the
fact is the vast majority of people in
the United States work jobs where
they're helping each other live better
lives but the artists have to pat
themselves on the back and is where I
was saying at the very beginning the
artisan Hollywood have to make
themselves feel important one of two
ways because otherwise they're just
reading lines for living and wearing
funny costumes so they have to make
themselves feel important one of two
ways one is they make important stories
right we're gonna make a story about a
black gay ute living in Miami right
that's going to be the thing that makes
us important or alternatively we have to
talk about how important we are to
everybody else now I don't get on the
air every morning and talk about how
important my job is right I don't
because you see they're important to
yours is not important to you but I
don't have to preach how important what
I do is to you because you'll decide for
yourself and I think that's true for the
vast majority people when you call a
plumber he doesn't show up to your house
and go you know what it's really
important I fix your toilet today I'm
the guy who stands between you and crap
running over your floor and the partner
doesn't do that just goes any fixes your
stuff but the artist community because
they understand that people sort of see
them as frivolous they feel the
necessity to go out and talk about how
special they are all the time and this
is
not under estimating art I love art I
love the movies I love books I love
plays I drew I love the arts I grew up
in the arch my dad was somebody in the
arse my mom is somebody in the art my
sister is somebody in the two of my
sisters are people in the art I love the
arts they're fantastic and I write
novels I love the arts but you know art
is wonderful it's enriching it can
connect us to each other but the ever
arrogance the true arrogance is saying
the only profession that celebrate what
it means to live a life I mean that's
really astounding you know well
celebrates like literally everyone does
you know who L celebrates what it means
to live a life morticians right we
actually put together the funeral
arrangements where we remember people
there's also something that's really
it's really high handed about saying
that only the lives we choose to honor
in Hollywood are the important ones Rick
she said in this speech she said there's
one place all the people with the
greatest potential are gathered the
graveyard people ask me all the time
what kind of stories do you want to tell
viola and I say exhume those bodies
exhumed those stories the stories of the
people who dream big I never saw those
dreams to fruition and this kind of
stuff goes over big in Hollywood mood
rings whoo the dreams okay but the
reality is the vast majority of people
in the graveyard their stories will
never be told but they are still
remembered by their family their impact
is still felt your life doesn't end when
your life ends unless Viola Davis
exhumes you and makes a story about you
you know with it that's not even real
right unless you affectional story about
a person who never existed know what
actually makes your life important is
the friends and family around you in the
way you impact the world in a better way
and the way you do honorable things for
friends and neighbors and make the world
a better place that's how you make the
world a better place there are a lot of
people who are remembered who are really
evil that doesn't make them more
important it doesn't make them more
special you know being remembered by
people who actually matter is I think
more important than Viola Davis
remembering you and the idea that
Hollywood is what confers value on
people is really kind of growth and
another element of this and some people
like this some people hated it I didn't
like it was Jimmy Kimmel did this
routine where he ushered in a bunch of
people off the Hollywood tour bus
directly into the Oscars and here's what
it looked like see the whole point of
this little shakier is to demonstrate
just how special Hollywood is it's so
special you can bring people in off the
street and then you can show them just
how magical Hollywood I mean look at all
these important people and look at all
these narrow do well rubes you know just
walking out what an honor for them what
an honor for them we brought in the
peasantry off the street and now the
peasants get to
hobnob with the hoi polloi they get to
be among the stars see what would have
been great honestly and would have been
funnier if Kimmel had before this taken
a bunch of the stars to visit people on
their actual jobs right had taken like
they make movies about these actual jobs
we've been really funny to take chris
pine for example in hell or high water
and take him to an oil derrick and let's
show them the people working in oil
derrick right or be really funny to take
nicole kidman and take her down to the
local plumbers Union and have her see
what people are actually doing over
there because that would have said okay
look we're Hollywood and we know what we
do is kind of frivolous and it brings
meaning to some people but we also
understand the what you do is really
important instead this whole event is
all about how Hollywood is super duper
important to all of our lives and look
it's fun I enjoy the Oscars as much of
the next style though I admit I did not
watch a lot of it last night but at the
same time this sort of this sort of i'm
going to look down on you because we're
from hollywood more special it manifests
itself not just in terms of general
attitude toward the towards the people
who live in the middle of the country
they're a bunch of rednecks and rubes it
also manifests itself in terms of
politics i'm going to talk more about
that in just a second but for that you
have to go over to daily wire calm right
now and subscribe you go for daily wire
calm eight bucks a month will make the
subscriber to daily wire.com you can use
the rest of the show live and check it
out over there you can also get an
annual subscription right now at daily
wire calm you get a free copy of a piece
of entertainment that's actually
conservative the arroyo if you watched
on friday we live stream the film's you
can actually see it the Arroyo is a
fictional film set on the southern
border about the crisis that's taking
place on our southern border 11 ranchers
land is overrun by the drug cartels and
he has to figure out what to do about it
if you want to get a free copy of that
free DVD that go to daily wire.com
become an annual subscriber otherwise
eight dollars a month makes you a
subscriber and we are later you can
listen to it on itunes or soundcloud by
the way if you listen on itunes leave us
a review we really appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you